I wrote the script right three years
previously actually filling it again
getting back my mind is real you know
she a script that hurts and I just had
court and the night went 0 school I was
able to actually find out worse than and
pull down exactly story one to tell at
which point it was great ready to be
done I went to school with Daniel and
Johnny and general zod losing here
general tso's always behind the camera
every point there's like vitamin yeah
5-7 videos we all just don't so good
once that happened we graduated and we
kind of knew that brought in our own
ways and this was a last shot you can
actually get one done right away i call
these suits because his suicide work
within a pretty short film i first wrote
l didn't go school called him on board
and he was all ready to go he was like
stoked about it then jan came on board
again Ian once we had that everybody
else just kind of fell into place
alright so so the idea that came to
three years ago yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of a pervert is he an Islamic
what happens when I goes back you know
but the Santiago story it's the statute
trying came here
kravin he didn't have to do and you know
everybody in every four sisters I'm
trying to show the cannabic some kind of
a struggle that you're going to at the
same time John I figure I hope you know
you know wrap it up and kind of a noir
crime film to kind of make audiences you
know really get involved I think the
last the last important backer was
bringing up the vinegar right in this
was our fun agreement and when we sent
gianna me that was a whole different
ball game I mean we rewrote seems coming
and going his strengths as soon as an
actor and it was just phenomenal kind of
just kept growing up for that no jump on
work it was really um when I first way I
was in next with my family having
Christmas and he said the screamer than
I get just with everything aside my
celebration my Christmas everything just
to reach the strip and everybody wants
it I remember that and it just the
character just draw me and I just kept
reading and reading and reading and I
just wanted to to be able for me was a
challenge because he's nothing like you
so for he was a challenge to be that I
don't know involved in that intense in
those situations so as soon as i read i
was like yes i'm in this for a minute I
mean to to make it more comfortable for
me but I was in from the beginning first
ride with professional work yeah i'm
gonna go to East LA I hang out with a
lot a lot of my homie but we're friends
to learn the sand to to know I
introduced them deeply to know more
about a girl or boy heel and all these
places I came from my character came
from and I just I don't know I started
researching and researching and debating
with Phillies here at OU every single
line with debate say from is more
comfortable Sadie's or that for him
sometimes he was locked with with his
idea so good for it anymore pretty well
that's what he's a direct object that
was pretty much it I mean a lot of
research and a lot of life I mean we had
so much love for this project that we
worked really hard on it iphone
rehearsals because we didn't have a
budget and uh every single shot was
pretty much a simple shot because we
have to Ryan shoot and run app actually
we were chased like a couple times
the idea was that's why the weird or so
long the idea what we're going to go in
there going to be ready to be prepped
one tank let's do this guy's what we got
is like okay now let's take 6 i'm going
to keep going together like I'm getting
arrested for the two and a couple of
times you clearly maybe we got chased
out of places and what was the mentality
why that decision why does it have it
we're not we're not going to cover this
scene within other the standard sort of
whatever clothes so it was all again
this Creek why why one shot the script
is told as you know come on man its
docking area first as become
progressively unravels itself it becomes
have like this dictionary so the story
of subhuman area which now we do is
displayed in within the sound design and
editing you know like all the time
searching like we were doing natural
first now we have it music montage and
now we have you kind of cut back to back
here so it's slowly time around it was
total sitting that way and again Dan
jammed the DPI what to do with kind of
approaching that with me and had a
period at all i'm going to do with that
being said though again I mean we we
didn't have a luxury the longest one
home take was an important 14 tapes 14
takes what Lucy was a it was my the one
that did it would be real honest people
never really well yeah where they were
just kind of talking backboard yeah
Carlos is shining it was many of the
reflections are aware people were
crossing it was just the end of the day
yeah we end we kept Osman how many days
there two days when the 30-day
production are two takes and decided to
move on and you know forcing with the
highest they've done around we did night
it when we only expected to do one
because you have people running around
with guns and blood and screaming you
know isn't a little today so we get
night and you know we just want to get
that perfect it was a lot going on a lot
of blocking a lot of things going on so
on the total number i'm not sure but
there wasn't it was the longest running
one thus birdie been seen probably where
we follow the camera in the apartment
from the stairs up way up all the way is
where we need to hang back how long is
that gonna ask you know that was
comforted that Daniel read here you know
how did have this project how many
profit land in your lap and can you talk
a little bit about you know your
preparation the rehearsal you know what
was that like for you it was pretty much
what he said was just uh he treated like
a plane pretty much so we were
practicing that for three months prior
to the project and I remember we call me
and I addition I starts oh that would be
a regular edition and they can be the
script I read it I mean suppose the bus
all before that I had done I did short
over here my past which was a very well
I like that
as a look at the camera but I thought I
had talked to villa theresa who wasn't
handling the camera he was the camera I
mean the DP was handling the camera and
we said was like all the way back there
so I'm going to look at him I absolutely
the camera and break that rule sorry
what that word again the rehearsals
helped a lot with that because I mean I
had to hit used to break those rules and
today is not to look at listen when he
stopped don't hold the sound just follow
the camera so that was really
challenging but I didn't really a
conscious with it reversal yeah we send
as always we send was always behind the
TV so I mean his well he was always
present there which made a little more
challenging for the actors because you
know he's there hanging behind the
camera so the eyes kind of want to
gravitate is so that Bell cute shamans
will come we're in that apartment
building and the we were almost done
shooting and then the crazy manager lady
came out and just oh man she plowed
through us pretty hard like what are you
guys doing here calling the cops you
gotta get out of here blah blah blah she
got scared us and it's like our first
days I'm gonna go on do you know it's
huh I don't think it was the noise quite
as much made a little bit and I'm always
call our bags and gear cases so that's
pretty
we'd like to like two or three fours
full of equipment just like in the
hallways let's see Jan could answer this
better but we travel light and I know
there was he knows of all right they say
you know the the burly man scene was
probably the most lit seen that we had
but we only had a couple of lights
running on that one most of those
natural lighting in the car we got some
mini kino lights that were stuck on the
roof on the inside most most natural
light the camera we used was a canon 7d
and with el cerrito ends that's correct
and John had a fab et al sound it was
very evil look fit in our trunk yeah we
may have trucks needed to spend our cars
basically winner for the calm mostly we
just can't run in the sound person fit
locations that would let itself to have
natural lighting at night the street
lights you know major there's no
combustibles over the country of even a
mexico from international festivals and
we kind of were kind of about 180 kind
of move on i have my two scripts s that
i kind of want to start working on just
find funding for knots but at the same
time I mean just today it's a mini Susan
day we just gotta accept it up or not
accepted on Seattle beat up on Gotham
City beautifully now st. Peter of the
film from other girls
releasing with the scope we do have
distribution deals like that in the
table bit explicit this one people
chatting short time you know out there
in your group make sure they let you do
another one absolutely feel it is all
right this great clip which means
everything else you're here let's put
back in and I did yeah we're just
working man everybody involved and I'm
very proud to be part of this and it's
just a very excellent my loss for words
right now no no yes everybody very proud
to be part to the s
yes the most reaction from the audience
is wherever we go and it's TEDx this is
like the first time you see it because
me and Daniel and they soon as I see the
indentations on million time crowds and
would be all like every time in every
time so to react and they do so it's
just as it's a great thing because i
sees president kennedy's behind maybe
we'll see him yeah we feel like you know
if it's incredible deal with that so
thank you